Okay, so now that we know that while sometimes we can be clever
a lot of the time we just can't test everything we would like.
How useful is any individual test case?
Is there any way to make a test case that is a little bit more useful in practice?
Let's look at this real quick--we just enqueued 7 into our
fixed-size queue and then immediately dequeue it.
So we should get 7 back out and if that's the case then we print success
and otherwise we have an error.
How useful is this? Let's go ahead and turn this into a quiz.
The question is if we passed this test case, what else have we learned
about our code or have we learned anything?
And your options are our code passes this one test case,
our code passes any test case where we replaced 7 with a different integer,
or our code passes many test cases where we replaced 7 with a different integer.
Check all that apply.